y listo y ansioso por entregar las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 al mundo el
departamento de carga de la aerolínea
lufthansa anunció el viernes que está
preparado para empezar a transportar los
precios sus antídotos creo que podríamos
ponernos en marcha inmediatamente si la
vacuna llegara aquí mañana seríamos
capaces de sacarla en el mismo día o
pasado esto es porque estamos bien
preparados ver si el transportista
alemán punto que había pasado meses ya
logando con las compañías farmacéuticas
para reunir las condiciones ideales de
entrega los diferentes países clientes
en efecto la vacuna desarrollada por
face viviente que tiene por ejemplo
requerimientos de almacenamiento
complejos y necesita ser mantenida a
menos 70 grados celsius pero lufthansa a
cargo aseguró que sus instalaciones
están a la altura para realizar la tarea
incluyendo la difícil logística de
llevar la vacuna desde el laboratorio al
almacén y al avión
muy cerca de aquí tenemos el llamado
centro de refrigeración donde todo tipo
de productos con diferentes requisitos
pueden ser enfriados a la temperatura
adecuada
esto necesita procedimientos especiales
pero también un sistema de control
hermético y eso es exactamente lo que
podemos ofrecer para luego transportar
el material
los expertos calculan que se necesitarán
15.000 vuelos y 15 millones de neveras
para transportar cada 10.000 millones de
dosis así como otras aerolíneas
lufthansa comenzado a retirar los
asientos de sus aviones de pasajeros
para poder llevar más de la valiosa
carga